very few people get the chance to do
that age 60 and usually at age 30 or 40
and that is to go back and take the road
not taken' Howell Raines and Walter
Isaacson on book TV Sunday 7:00 p.m.
Eastern on c-span to fiery speeches
newspaper columns and allegations of
adultery made Minister an abolitionist
Henry Ward Beecher brother of Harriet
Beecher Stowe one of America's first
celebrities Debbie Applegate details his
life on her new biography the most
famous man in America this talk from the
Harriet Beecher Stowe's Center in
Hartford Connecticut is an hour ten
minutes ladies and gentlemen good
evening welcome to the Harriet Beecher
Stowe Center I'm Katherine Kane and the
executive director of the Harriet
Beecher Stowe Center and we're just
delighted you're here for this long
awaited event I know some of you know
how long it is you've been involved
we're very delighted to have you here
the Harriet Beecher Stowe Center was the
last home of Harriet Beecher Stowe and
of course she was even more famous than
Henry Ward Beecher her favorite brother
there were eleven features in that
generation and they were into everything
and they were into every issue of the
day of the mid 19th century and Henry
was almost as well known as I said as
his sister Harriet Beecher Stowe and we
use all of that historic content around
the Beecher's and Harriet Beecher Stowe
herself at the Stowe Center we use that
historic content to connect the past and
the president and try and inspire people
to take positive action along those
around those themes that the that
Stowe's of Beecher's worked so hard on
themes of American freedom and humanity
and equality so welcome tonight and I
have to tell you I'm I've had a good go
at this book I was lucky enough that we
got here at the Stowe center a galley
copy so I
I had a preview and it's really good
it's really good when I joined the
Harriet Beecher Stowe Center seven plus
years ago in the first few months I was
here Debbie Applegate arrived and I we
were talking in our research library
she came to use our collection here and
she said that she had a book contract to
do a book on Henry Ward Beecher and I
was delighted to hear that because I
don't think he gets enough attention but
now he will and she said that her book
contract said that she would have her
book ready in six months and I think I
bit my tongue
I remember thinking that's exciting
six months Henry Ward Beecher and how
many years later from them so it's seven
years after that and you've been working
for many years so we're very happy today
to have Debbie Applegate with us to talk
about her new book the most famous man
in America Henry Ward Beecher the
biography of Henry Ward Beecher and
Debbie will talk and then we will have a
book signing and some refreshments and
we'll also after Debbie's talk have a
little time for questions we hope and
dialogue because that's part of
everything we try so let me introduce
Debbie Applegate to talk about Henry
Ward Beecher
thank you very much Catherine - and
thank you to everyone here at the stove
Center who have helped me so much over
the last seven years it's a little bit
maybe a little more than seven years
believe it at that and thank you to all
the people I know there are a lot of
people who drove quite a ways to come
here and I really appreciate it I'm
going to speak without amplification as
Henry Ward Beecher did but please as you
can he of course also spoke without
notes but I I'm gonna have to use notes
but if anyone can't hear me please just
kind of make a little noise it's a
special pleasure to be here of all
places because this is where I came as
soon as I signed the book contract this
is where I was gonna come I thought I
just had a little little cleanup
research to do I would spend about a
month here in the archives and then I
would zip zip it would be all done and
of course I was dead wrong but since
then I have returned many many times and
this is one of the most comfortable
places I know actually and one of the
loveliest places I know where everyone
is very nice and it has been always been
very nice to me so this opportunity to
repay your hospitality means a great
deal to me now as many of you know
because I'm sure many of you have been
here many many times a lot of the places
where the Beecher family lived have been
remarkably well preserved in the view
Kollek village of Litchfield not very
far from here remains remarkably like it
was when Beecher grew up there in the
1810s and 1820s in Boston it's possible
to attend the Hanover or Park Street
churches where Lyman and Edward Beecher
preached it's possible stroll through
Beacon Hill where the Beecher spent so
much of their time and really picture
them there and even in New York City
which you know changes so much Brooklyn
Heights where Beecher lived for a good
half of his life looks almost exactly
like it did when he strolled the streets
there when he that's where he came to
fame
but this place I really believe that the
Stowe Center that nook farm is the
spiritual home of the Beecher's now in
the 21st century and I really believe
that this is where they most come alive
which makes it a little easier for me to
be here because it's fitting that I've
been asked here to perform what I think
of as a very difficult trick that is to
resurrect a once world-famous but now
long-forgotten historical figure this is
the literary equivalent of trying to
raise the dead but being here makes it a
lot easier because in fact Nick farm is
where Henry's little sister Isabella
Beecher Hooker became a believer in
spiritualism often holding seances to
try to communicate with the dead loved
ones including Beecher so I feel like I
have good precedence here I was as
Katharine alluded I was only 18 years
old when I discovered Henry Beecher and
some of you actually were around at that
time I was a scholarship student working
at eros caught in the Amherst College
Library in Massachusetts when my boss at
the library asked me to put together an
exhibit on some famous alumni Amherst
College was established by
Congregationalists in 1821 to fight what
they called the Unitarian Menace
spreading from Boston it was the Citadel
the fight the Unitarians Beecher had
graduated in the class of 1834 on his
way to the ministry the problem was that
I had never heard of Henry Ward Beecher
so the first thing I had to do was I had
to figure out what feature had been
famous for and now this was back in the
olden days before the internet so I
turned to history books almost all of
them made brief mention of the famous
minister Henry Ward Beecher usually they
made mention of his anti-slavery antics
like auctioning slave girls to freedom
from the Plymouth church pulpit or
sending rifles which were nicknamed
Beacher's Bibles to the Free State
settlers in Kansas fighting the scourge
of slavery but that was about it it
would be like a line or two
we've been almost every index but that
would be it he was literally a footnote
to history
well I figured there had to be more to
him than that so I dug deeper I pulled
out old newspaper articles and search
through crumbling volumes and it turned
out as you all know now that Henry was
one of a very large outspoken an
eccentric family who for two generations
loomed larger than life on the American
stage as a family
the Beacher's possessed a reputation
that equal to any of the great mythic
clans of American history including the
Addams is the James is the Roosevelt's
North Kennedys as one common 19th
century saying put it this country is
inhabited by Saints sinners and
Beecher's and you know bear with me if
it feels like I'm preaching to the choir
but as all the visitors to the snow
center know the head of the family was
Lyman Beecher one of the very last great
parent Puritan ministers in America
famous for his Christian political
activism Lyman Beecher insisted that all
seven of his sons become ministers and
each brought their own idiosyncrasies to
the calling Edward was a highly
respected scholar and editor Thomas was
an innovator in the field of social
services and James was a chaplain for an
african-american army regiment and a
missionary Catherine he's done of course
the daughters as we all know were even
more remarkable than the sons Katharine
Beecher was a pioneer educator of women
and author of over a dozen books
Isabella Beecher hooker was a radical
women's rights activist but of course
the celebrity of Harriet outstripped
them all Harriet Beecher Stowe was the
most famous woman in the
english-speaking world by far bar none
having sold millions of copies of her
novels and dozens of languages in fact I
should say to this day whenever I talk
about Harry ward beecher in any way for
the last 20 years
most people look totally blank until I
mention Harriet and Uncle Tom's Cabin
and then they're immediately off yes yes
and I have to say I'm sure that Peter
would be I'm sure Henry would be
chagrined but not at all surprised even
back in the 1860s he was occasionally
introduced as the Reverend Harry excuse
me the Reverend Henry Ward Beecher Stowe
pretty often actually evolved feature of
all to beat your children
Henry success was the most surprising
born in 1813 Henry or Hank as they
called him was the eighth child of 12 a
bubbly boisterous boy who chafed against
his solemn religious upbringing in his
brilliant competitive siblings frankly
no one expected very much of him as a
youngster he was bored by school he was
bashful among adults and he was a cut-up
around his friends while his siblings
were emulating their father by
memorizing Bible verses and he would
always complain that Harriet got all the
memory and he was left with none of them
which might be an excuse but it was true
she had a brilliant memory and he had
none he would entertain his friends by
mounting a well they were off
imitating Lyman and you know studying
and really thinking about religion
praying he would often entertain his
friends by mounting a hay stack wearing
an old pair of glasses he'd scavenge
from somewhere and would stand up at the
top of this haystack mimicking his
father delivering a sermon and then as
for his grand finale he would somersault
dramatically down the haystack as his
friends roared with laughter of all his
siblings
Henry was closest to Harriet she was two
years older than him and she was really
his only true confidant as a child and
even into adulthood she really shared a
lot of his feelings and like him they
both they both wore their longing for
love on their shirtsleeves
yet even Harriet could make him feel
inferior simply by making him seem so
ordinary in comparison as Lyman wrote to
his brother-in-law
when Henry was eight and Harriet was six
excuse me when Harry was eight and Henry
was six Harriet is a great genius I
would give a hundred dollars if she or a
boy and Henry was a girl she is as odd
as she is intelligent studious Henry is
Henry grown older and learning some bad
things from bad boys but on the whole a
lovely child but being a lovely child
was not enough to stand out among the
teachers like many Yankee children in
this era
religion was discourage of Henry's
childhood his father's religion as he
remembered my innumerable shortcomings
and misdemeanors were to my mind so many
pimples that marked my terrible
depravity and I never had the remotest
idea of God except that he was a
sovereign who sat with a sceptre in his
hand and he had his eye on me and said I
see you and I am after you so I used to
live in perpetual fear and dread and
often wish myself dead and yet terrified
as Henry was of hell and damnation and
the devil which Lyman preached hell and
talked about the devil but it was really
he did wasn't that so much as the
culture around him I much as Henner was
afraid of hell he really could not
muster much enthusiasm for heaven either
because everything had been told and
this is this is his description from
everything he'd been told heaven sounded
like a really dull place where all the
Angels stood around in white robes
singing hymns and telling God what they
thought of him as Henry put it I did not
like it and I thought I was a miserable
wretch because I did not like it as a
teenager Henry tried to flee his fate
the beach her fate by threatening to run
away to sea but in the end Henry loved
Lyman too much to abandon or disappoint
him how did I come to be a preacher
Henry asked years later it was fate I
suppose that's all I do not think I can
honestly assign any other reason to it I
took the preaching as my brothers did
simply because nobody ever dreamed of my
father's boys doing anything else that's
all there is to it although he was
unable to escape the ministry as soon as
he was done with his schooling Beecher
lit out for the western frontier of
Indiana preaching in log cabins and
raucous open-air camp meetings he shook
off his stiff Yankee training developing
an emotional melodramatic style all of
his own soon he found that the less he
preached of his father's old testament
style fire and brimstone theology and
the more he spoke of Christ's love and
healing the more people flocked to him
in 1847 when Beecher was 34 years old he
was discovered by several wealthy New
York businessman who lured him and his
young family back east
to the up-and-coming suburb of Brooklyn
New York here in New York then as now
the capital of what we call the mass
media and the entertainment industry's
Henry's eccentric combination of Western
informality Eastern education and
unabashed showmanship made him an
overnight sensation
he began drawing huge audiences right
away with his all-forgiving New
Testament gospel of love and his
emotionally soul-baring sermons and
lectures when Harriet visited beat
Brooklyn in 1850 on her way to move up
to Brunswick where she would write the
book this was before she was famous when
she was still a poor fairly obscure
Parsons wife she was absolutely shocked
by how her little brother had suddenly
grown in stature and was especially
shocked by his prosperity which was very
unbeaten Ike as she put it she wrote to
her father
Henry's people are more in love with him
and than ever and have raised his salary
to three thousand three hundred dollars
and given him a beautiful horse and
carriage worth $600 you know the fact
that he she knew exactly how much it
cost and was really appalled and in fact
got it wrong she under counted his
salary as he pointed out it wasn't long
before the local newspapers were
reporting Beecher's are removed as
telegraph lines spread across the
country these stories were picked up by
regional papers extending his fame and
soon Henry was making a tidy fortune
writing a regular newspaper column and
traveling the railroad delivering witty
dramatic speeches on the hot topics of
the day and in 1850 the year Harriet
passed through the year he really began
his climb to fame the hottest of all
topics was slavery following the
conservative lead of Lyman Beecher both
Henry and Harriet had long shied away
from the slavery debate as to divisive
and too violent literally too violent
and an era where it was easier to raise
a mob than a square dance
quite simply especially in
anti-evolution mom even in later years
neither Harriet nor Henry were radical
abolitionists like William Lloyd
Garrison garrison who was willing to
repudiate both the Bible and the
Constitution because they supported
slavery and here I know many of you know
this but it is really worth pointing out
that the Bible really
is one of the biggest obstacles to
abolition since slavery is deeply
embedded embedded in the Bible and
really at no point forbidden in the
Bible and sometimes even counts as a
reward that got you know God has given
such prosperity to his favorite subjects
especially in the Old Testament and
especially in verses chapters like
Leviticus where it's openly endorsed but
both Henry and Harriet were outraged
when Congress passed the compromise of
1850 a big omnibus bill that allowed
California to enter the union as a non
slave state a free state in exchange for
a series of concessions to the slave
power in the south the most inflammatory
provisions were the Fugitive Slave laws
which required northern citizens to hunt
down and return runaway slaves or face a
stiff fine and jail time possibly now
Anna Ward Beecher was a man of many
contradictions for all of his talk of
love all his playfulness all his genuine
lovable Nasseri much a man of war he had
what he called a conceited conscience
they would not let him go once it was
riled up or as he put it another way I
am a peace man except when I wish to
fight pushed by this graceful compromise
of 1850 Beecher finally threw himself
whole hog into the battle against
slavery writing lecturing and
sermonizing against the evil slave
officee and it's wicked minions in
Washington this was obviously before a
church could lose its tax-exempt status
for preaching politics
he's pyrotechnics in the pulpit and the
new and in the newspapers earned him
even more notoriety and scorn but it was
Harriet of course who caught fire
inspired by her loathing in the Fugitive
Slave laws she began writing a
serialized newspaper story entitled
Uncle Tom's Cabin or the man who was a
thing
facing the title character on a former
slave who used to work for Henry in
Indianapolis Uncle Tom's Cabin as many
of you know who have read it combined
keen-eyed social realism with a
sentimental faith and the redemptive
power of love
it's a 600 page emotional rollercoaster
climaxing with the murder of the pious
slave uncle
and the escape of Eliza the beautiful
mulatto slave mother along the
Underground Railroad to Canada by the
third installment of this odd and
fascinating tale readers were writing to
the surprised editor saying they had
never read anything so rich and
thrilling when Harriet missed an
installment several weeks later
impatient protests streamed into the
editors office but that was nothing
compared to the cry that rose when
Harriet killed off the character of
little Eva the slave and her saintly
daughter in the December issue by
Christmas besotted readers were
besieging Harriet with requests for
daguerreotype sand autographs it seemed
as if everyone was reading it even those
who had no interest in slavery even
those who thought navel novels were not
respectable
that is to say everyone was reading it
except Henry as Henry joked I have made
it a rule in my life to read none of the
writings of my relatives and with two or
three exceptions I have really stuck to
that rule and he certainly wasn't going
to enjoy the suspense of reading it in a
serialized form because it was meant to
be painfully suspenseful as he said I
will not go through the excitement which
it will give me a week-by-week I prefer
to take it all in one dose so the book
appeared in hardcover on March 20th 1852
selling three thousand copies on the
very first day a an excellent plan I
think
now Henry to clarity you would he was
going to read it he was gonna read it
all at once
so he began at the breakfast table it
was well into the second bag was it was
a triple-decker back in first came out
as well under the second volume by the
time his wife Eunice what's bad I soon
began to cry remembered Henry and then I
went and I shut up all the doors for I
didn't want anyone to see me cry and
then I sat down to it and finished it
that night for I knew that the only way
I would be able to preach on Sunday was
if I finished him of course his wife we
waited up for him she's a very devoted
wife finally as the clock struck three
o'clock in the morning he came upstairs
and threw the book down on the bed in
front of her exclaiming if how he still
ever writes another book like that I I
well she almost killed me
now what's fascinating about Henry and
Harriet as anti-slavery heroes is that
they offered no new solutions to the
political and economic impasse of
slavery I mean Henry actually had a lot
of thoughts and he had a lot of you know
things to say about it but they really
were and they very political they were
both very political and they studied the
subject deeply but they didn't really
offer those kinds of solutions instead
they hit on a strategy that created
empathy for actual black people bridging
the alienation of color and bondage and
binding the listener to the slave if
only for a moment by the common longings
of human nature
Henry stunts like auctioning young slave
girls to freedom from the pulpit of
limit search while asking listeners to
imagine their own daughters being sold
into a life of rape and blone
bone-crushing labor and you can imagine
how shocking that was his stunts like
that had very much the same effect and
we're meant to have the same effect as
Harriet's novel when she made readers
cry when they were reading about Uncle
Tom's brutal death or when she made
their pulses race when she breathlessly
described Eliza's race across the icy
river with the slave hunters behind her
through the power of their words and
their feelings Henry and Harriet enticed
people often against their will into
putting themselves into the shoes of the
slave they exploited the contradictions
of the human heart
what is abstract and far away is never
as moving as what is intimate and in the
flesh in the 20th century many critics
belittled the Beacher's both of them
both of their anti-slavery work as
sentimental and unsystematic and
pandering to white prejudice but I think
such criticism miss reads the average
mind the mind of the average American in
the 19th century it really was a radical
thing a radical thing indeed to persuade
free right free whites to feel a genuine
kinship with enslaved blacks this
imaginative emotional exercise was
crucial to recognizing black Americans
as fellow citizens
we can complain the beecher was no way
in lloyd garrison but what made Henry so
valuable to the cause was his uncanny
instinct for being just one step ahead
of conventional wisdom just far enough
to seem original or bold but not so far
as to frighten this audience so
Harriet's sudden fame brought Henry just
he was already getting famous he was
already getting big he was actually much
more famous than her and all of a sudden
that catapulted it up and the whole
Beecher clan all of a sudden you know
Lyman who had been a very controversial
figure is now a beloved figure the
father of more brains than any other
American and of course to even greater
heights of notoriety because of course
they also made them much more employment
Church became one of the very first mega
churches it had about 2,000 official
members and seating for nearly 3,000
including standing-room-only spots in
the aisles this was obviously before
modern fire regulations and it was
filled every Sunday at least every
Sunday that Beecher preached and here I
should say that if you ever have the
chance to go to New York and you're in i
really suggest going to brooklyn heights
it really is beautiful and it looks
almost exactly like when Beecher was
there it's the first historical district
in the country actually and Plymouth
churches is almost exactly the way it
was you can go in and you can really
picture him there and it and and they
have also kept the mission like the snow
center of civil rights and equality
that's been really worth doing so within
a decade of arriving in Brooklyn Henry
had become New York's number one tourist
attraction this was back when you know
you it wasn't respectable for most
people for women and children to go to
the theater so church was one of the big
entertainment so he really become New
York's number one tourist attraction so
wildly popular that the fairies from
Manhattan to Brooklyn were dubbed
feature boats and when asked how to get
to Beatrice Church once you got off the
ferry locals just said follow the crowd
that was kind of the joke and the truth
as one Manhattan hotel clerk observed I
have known visitors to spend Saturday
night in gambling halls and all kinds of
wicked places and then sit
for hours so as to be sure it can be in
time to hear mr. Beecher preach soon
Beecher was hobnobbing with the great
literary figures the day Ralph Waldo
Emerson Ralph Waldo Emerson declared
Beecher a paragon of self-reliance and a
true transcendentalist in his own way in
turn Beecher popularized many of
Emerson's more abstract ideas in
contrast when Henry David Thoreau
visited Plymouth church to see Beecher
preach he was deeply offended by
Beecher's vast self-confidence
confidence in his knowledge and his
flamboyant style and he declared him a
pagan and wrote in his diary
if Henry Ward Beecher and I always think
the rows little crabby so I think this
is my opinion I've always thought that
but this confirmed Henry Ward Beecher
knows so much more about God than others
people do if he has made some discovery
of truth in this direction I would thank
him to publish in silliman scientific
journal with his few flourishes as
possible he much preferred what Whitman
Thoreau did on that visit and Walt
Whitman although they were no more than
passing acquaintances Walt Whitman also
a brooklynite felt a tremendous kinship
with feature Beecher was given a first
edition of Leaves of Grass and Whitman
was convinced that the preacher in his
words stole terrifically from it in his
servants
Beecher's combination of passionate
impulses and moderate instincts was
particularly particularly admired by
Abraham Lincoln although Lincoln himself
was not conventionally religious
Lincoln's law partner William Herndon
and his wife Mary Todd were huge fans of
features and when Lincoln came to New
York to give his legendary Cooper Union
address during the presidential campaign
of 1860 Lincoln twice took the ferry to
Brooklyn to see Beecher preach and was
held spellbound
in fact the Cooper Union address the
famous speech that one linked in the
presidency was originally supposed to be
delivered in Plymouth church but was
moved to Manhattan when the weather
turned bad the high point of Beecher's
unofficial political career came during
the Civil War when he gave a series of
speeches in England which helped ensure
the beat that Britain would not
recognize diplomatically the Confederacy
at the end of the war Lincoln was so
grateful
he asked Beecher to raise the flag over
Fort Sumter which had been recently
recaptured it was the first flag raising
on southern soil near the very end of
the war saying as Lincoln put it without
Beecher there might have been no flag to
raise after the war Beecher seemed
invincible he hobnobbed with politicians
reformers artists and writers he was in
constant demand as a speaker or writer
he grew bolder with his unorthodox ideas
and behavior he promoted unconventional
ideas like women's suffrage and
Darwinian evolution for example and
announced that he no longer believed in
many core Christian concepts like hell
he appeared in advertisements for
products like throat lozenges and
insurance companies made quite a bit of
money so you even got his wife his wife
she advertised
um I cops which I doubt sure what they
were supposed to do but some improve
your vision and he even published a
novel called Norwood it wasn't a great
novel it still is not a great novel but
as he liked to joke it finally lay to
rest the long-standing rumor that it was
he not Harriet who had written Onkel
Thomas Kevin but it still became a
best-seller and like Uncle Tom's Cabin
also a play that big best-selling play
they can't so even went Beecher was
pummeled by the press and by many
politicians and many of his fans for
advocating leniency for the defeated
south his popularity did not wane
but then it all fell apart in 1870
Beecher was accused by his former friend
and protege Theodore Tilton of seducing
Tilton's wife Elizabeth Elizabeth was
also one of each year's most pious
parishioners two years later feminist
firebrand Victoria Woodhull also the
known as a spiritualist and a women's
rights activist and the first woman to
run for president published the story
letting loose a firestorm in the press
suddenly the gospel of love seemed to
rationalize a life of lust the ensuing
scandal and civil trial for what they
called criminal conversation created
more headlines in the
entire civil war now and to those who
said think that sounds preposterous that
how could it be more than some more
I should explain this partially because
there was a wartime news blackout from
the battlefield and it's also true that
after the war just the number of
newspapers exploded exponentially but it
is true that it's worth them you know
doing the equivalent of googling if you
have access to like in the New York
Times database the Brooklyn Eagle which
is free online and if you punch in his
name just thousands and thousands and
thousands of hits come and hits I don't
even call them that but that's it thank
y'all come up from the scandal it's
really remarkable so you have to
remember when I began discovering love
this about Beecher he was only 18 years
old I was only a student just putting
together a little exhibit in the college
library but by the time I was done with
the exhibit I was absolutely hooked on
the Beecher's and btran Henry in
particular I loved Henry surprisingly
modern sense of humor his irreverence
and his enthusiasm and especially he's
really open-minded open-hearted approach
to life and frankly like everyone else
you know I found him lovable so now I
had solved the mystery or at least the
mystery to me of why he'd been famous
and I'd solved the second mystery of why
he'd been forgotten after all there is
nothing like a national sex scandal to
spoil one's place in history especially
for a minister but all this left me with
yet another far more difficult mystery
to solve
did Beecher actually commit adultery
with Elizabeth Tilton so I decided to
write a college seminar paper on Beecher
focusing on the scandal that turned into
a senior thesis and then still unable to
resist features siren call I decided to
earn a PhD where he became the subject
of my dissertation but my graduate
school advisers were more interested in
lofty subjects of like the mass media
and historical arguments about the
middle class and the war than in solving
that nagging but sordid mystery so I've
set aside the scandal question finally I
decided the only way to get to the
bottom
facts as Henry called them was to
research and write a book
after so many years are working on
Beecher I figure it would be a snap
that's when I came here I find that
initial contract that gave me a
year-and-a-half deadline wasn't six
months did give me a year but that was
in 1998 so now let me tell you writing
about hot-button topics like religion
and politics is sensitive business by
any measure and here the Stowe Center I
have met some descendants of the Beecher
and and they have most of them have now
passed away because I've been working on
it for that long but they were and they
were indeed very sensitive that older
generation about these things it's so
still the history is not that far away
just stay out of trouble your research
has to be scrupulously accurate your
judgment has to be empathetic yet
even-handed but religion and politics
are nothing compared to the sensitivity
when writing about whether a beloved
Christian minister has seduced a member
of his own flock the trouble was the
testimony and there is miles and miles
of it was so internally contradictory
with both Henry and Elizabeth Tilton
contradicting themselves each other and
themselves several times each that is
very difficult to know who or what to
believe now there is no question this is
absolutely factual Beecher was an
unusually flirtatious man girl crazy I
think is the technical term and there is
no question that his marriage was
troubled and that many of his female
fans were infatuated with him but of
course this is no proof of an affair and
God forbid that it would be in fact
Beecher's friends often defended him by
saying that people and merely
misunderstood his flirtatious warmth and
even after six months of testimony the
jury at the trial could not decide
whether beech was guilty after weeks of
painful deliberation the jury finally
died deadlocked nine to three benign
jurors in favor of feature and three
against now this sort of unsolved
mystery is a great opportunity for a
biographer a great thing for a biography
but it is also an enormous challenge
they can steal years of your time trust
me when I first began this book everyone
presumed that I would diligently search
through the historical archives here and
elsewhere and find The Smoking Gun that
would settle the question of Beecher's
infidelity and I did I searched high and
low for industy old volumes and
crumbling letters that had not been
touched in a hundred years I wrote to
historical societies and archives around
the country asking for anything related
to the Beecher's I watched in wonder as
the digital revolution arrived making it
possible to search through far-off
libraries and read rare documents online
when I first began this project in the
mid-1980s no one had ever heard of the
Internet
now there are literally thousands upon
thousands of documents about Henry Ward
Beecher available at the touch of a
keyboard and I did find a lot I found
out a great deal and I found out the
Beecher really did have an indisputable
pattern of surprisingly intimate
relationships with women other than his
wife but none of this got me any closer
to answering the question of whether
Elizabeth Tilton and Henry Ward Beecher
had made love on the sofa for the
sitting room back in nineteen in 1868
then out of the blue a smoking gun did
drop into my lap I was sitting at the
kitchen table of a private collector in
Manhattan who collects books and
documents mostly related to Harriet she
pulled out a long letter written in
beautiful cursive handwriting it was
addressed to any would-be teacher but I
had no date no signature no return
address except for the name rooster
Beach scrawled much much later on the
back and the letter was terribly sad and
told a really very sad story the author
of the letter described the agony of
silently watching his wife home more and
more and more in love with Beecher over
the prior 10 years with heartbreaking
detail he told it their first visit
supplement our infatuation had grown
from there until this very night when he
arose from his sleepless bed as he put
it to beg Beecher to somehow release him
from his grief and pain now stunning as
this was
it had nothing to do with the Tilton
scandal this was an entirely new affair
being discussed an entirely new wife an
entirely new cuckold but it seemed to
support the oft-repeated claim the
feature at a pattern of adultery with
his parishioners in fact during the
height of the scandal it was often said
I mean even before when rumors were
swirling Beecher preaches to seven or
eight of his mistresses every Sunday
which I don't think well I don't know I
guess but I don't have any proof of that
that's for sure so off I went on another
goose chase this one reached a glorious
climax of several years ago in the
Hudson Valley basement of the elderly
Brewster beach named on the back as he
pulled out a photo of his great aunt
violet who was the spitting image of
Henry ward beecher you can see the
photos in the book if you're interested
now of course no one can ever really
know what happens in the privacy of
Beecher study or Elizabeth Tilton
sitting-room or really perhaps anyone's
most intimate relationships and without
modern DNA evidence of course I cannot
be certain that violet was Beecher's
love child so in the book I lay out the
evidence and tell the stories I know as
best I could
allowing the readers to make his or her
own judgment
just like those twelve jurymen and the
Beecher trial but I would like to close
by saying that I did not write this book
I did not take up the Beecher's to make
it a sensational expose of hypocrisy I
think like his friend Ralph Waldo
Emerson who warned against the
hobgoblins of foolish consistency
feature did not believe that
contradictions were the same thing as
hypocrisy Henry's older brother Edward
liked to tell a story about how the two
of them were talking with some other
ministers about the concept of
punishment after death hell after Henry
gave what Edward called his latest
opinion on the subject Edward finally
had to object but you took nearly the
opposite view in a sermon six weeks ago
well if I said it then I believed it
then Beecher replied I never say
anything I don't believe
I think this is a more valuable thing
than we often realize it matters of
religion politics even love
Beecher's life demonstrates how often
our weaknesses come from the same well
as our strengths in fact they need to
grapple with our sins is often what
drives our greatest accomplishments in
politics features persuasive power his
ability to intuit what people needed to
hear came precisely from his unstable
mixture of impulsive passion and
moderate instincts in a religion Henry
showed how closely the yearning for
heavenly love and earthly love are
linked they are not the polar opposites
of sin and saintliness but different
ways of responding to the same human
longings of course more than ones over
the last seven twenty years I have
nearly disparity of unraveling Beecher's
fascinating Henry's fascinating
contradictions but at those moments I
like to console myself by murmuring to
myself the words of his fellow
Brooklynite Walt Whitman and I like them
especially because I think Beecher
himself would have embraced this
explanation as women put a do i
contradict myself very well then I
contradict myself I am large I contain
multitudes
some of you drove far enough do you feel
like you really have to get an extra
round again if anyone would like to ask
questions I would be delighted to answer
any anything anyone asks excuse me I'm
sorry I need to because CNN is very
kindly taping this I need to obscure
gosh okay
I'm not really primetime ready obviously
wait would anyone who would like to ask
a question could you just wait a moment
till we get the microphone - thanks time
memorizing as a child was actually
envious of his sister Harriet and yet
you spoke or you mentioned that he spoke
without notes which I found fascinating
what happened you know how was he able
to get up in front of so many people and
become the most famous man in America
without notes well he described it this
way he said well you know some men like
their bread hot and some like them cold
I like mine hot and what he meant was he
would all he wouldn't memorize he
wouldn't write it ahead he would not as
he got older you know once he got
comfortable and up here and pulpit he he
would write his sermons on Sunday
morning or Saturday night and he would
just he had practiced so much he had
just preached so much like all of the
Beecher's it's often seven nights a week
that that time out in the in the West
was critical he did the circuit he was
almost like a Methodist circuit writer
preaching several at least several times
a week and often preaching at big camp
meetings so that by the time he got you
know to Brooklyn he really had it in him
like he just he knew the Bible from
reading it he couldn't quote it even
when he was standing up here even to the
end of his life he would still need to
have the Bible right in front of him to
read from it but everything else
he had in him and his best speeches were
absolutely the ones that the most
pyrotechnical the ones that really
grabbed people the most were the ones
that he did most spontaneously
unfortunately they don't read as well
for that reason and that's part of why
he his fame doesn't linger
you know seeing him was a very different
experience I think oh yes I gotta run
sorry please thank you if you don't mind
Katherine doing that thank you he had a
speech impediment as a child and a very
thick tongue how did he overcome that or
at what age was he able to rise above
that well that's that's something I
really actually spend some time with in
the book because he didn't really this
speech impediment was an odd thing it
arose only it didn't it wasn't true when
he was very little wasn't true when he
was first learning to talk it was really
only after his mother died at the age of
three his beloved mother and one of the
sad parts about the book is I did not
get to write as much about Lyman and
roxanna's marriage as I wished I think
they are I'm an Beecher and his first
wife I think are one of the great love
stories in American history
and when Roxana died when Beecher was
when Henry was three it's trouble with
calling everyone feature when Henry was
three the house was just enshrouded in
sadness and they couldn't ever find a
good reason why he had this speech
impediment that they called it he didn't
you know they thought they called it in
a large palette or her tonsils or you
know something but it really it was
nothing I think it was honest-to-god
just stress and that it faded it faded
within a year too and very quickly he
could talk just fine he just didn't like
to talk around adults
when the scandal broke what did all of
these distinguished siblings do did they
back him up or did they just be quiet or
what did they do it's a very it was a
very big to do actually the siblings of
course because heaven forbid the the
beach here and if one Beecher was in hot
water every one of them had to somehow
be involved and had to have their say or
send their letters or are often as
Katherine in particular like to do send
her letters to the press and so almost
all of them backed him and Harriet above
all Harriet was absolutely devoted to
Henry and even when he I mean to be
quite honest I think that once he moved
to Brooklyn he was ready to not leave
the family behind but he was feeling
worldly and he and Harriet was quite
hurt and it was really her becoming
famous that risa mented their
relationship and I know this makes him
sound shallow but it really Risa mented
this their relationship and she really
was his closest sibling so she and the
others she and Catherine and Mary were
absolutely devoted they went to
Catherine and Mary went to the trial
they stuck by him Harriet was so upset
that she couldn't stand to be here
during the trial so she went to Florida
and stayed in Florida the whole time but
begged sent letters every single day
begging them send on send me all the
newspaper reports so you know obviously
the wanted to know but couldn't stand it
his brothers basically all supported him
the one exception was his Abela and
isabella had become had been very
involved in the women's rights movement
and the women's rights movement had been
the the seedbed of the scandal and some
to some extent that the where it all
burst out and she was a big follower of
Victoria Woodhull she was a spiritualist
and believed that Victoria Woodhull was
really a real Oracle from heaven and she
also really was knew how bad Henry's
marriage was she had certainly seen him
flirt he had been that way his whole
life he and when she was 14 when
Isabella was 14
her best friend had had a terrible crush
out in Cincinnati on Henry even after he
was engaged so much so that you know all
the parents said you just can't have
young Beecher come visiting every day
the way he does they're forbidden so she
had had some feeling that this was
perhaps true and I think maybe the other
everyone knew his marriage was bad all
the siblings were well aware she wasn't
Eunice wasn't very nice to his siblings
and yet the rest of them just shut their
eyes and couldn't even contemplate it
and it meant that isabella was cast out
she was not invited to the funeral she
was not allowed to she had to stand in
line with the 50,000 other people who
came to see in Lion State it was very
sad and after and she did reconcile
Harriet reconciled with her a little bit
some of the other siblings not units
never spoke to her again the wife but
after Henry died Isabella was sure that
Henry was coming and speaking to her
from heaven and forgave and asked her
forgiveness that Henry asked her
forgiveness for having cut her out and
treated her so Shapley during the trial
oh I told us an awful lot but there's
one more thing I want to know although I
am going to read the book because the
pressure by Mark feature or she what
happened was poor Elizabeth she really
is a very sad figure in that she was
just so in love with Beecher and so and
deeply in love with her husband and
there was a lot of clash between
Theodore and Henry especially over
politics and it's one of the nice things
I think about the book is you get to see
that politics and the sex and the
politics and the religion really all do
affect each other and so she supposed
again I I want I really do want to leave
this to the reader because I absolutely
cannot say 100% for sure but here's how
it went was she after much pressure from
her husband her
very jealous husband who had heard all
these rumors and thought something was
going on
pressured her into confessing she
confesses and this is fact these are
facts you can believe what the content
visit effect so she confesses Tilton
Theodore Tilton goes in tells Beecher
well I know now I know you're young I
could run you out of Brooklyn and you
know ruin your career if I want these
features let me go at least say one last
word to Elizabeth I can't believe she
would say this is true theater lets him
go he goes to his Elizabeth he makes it
he convinces Elizabeth to retract it to
retract it in writing so then he comes
back theater finds out he's furious he
goes back to Elizabeth he makes
Elizabeth retract her retraction in
writing so part of it was they kept
writing everything down I mean that's
why we know so much about this they had
some you know first people who were all
spontaneous nonetheless they had a real
belief in the contractual power of the
written word and and then during the
trial eventually she leaves the Attar
she she decides she's gonna go with
Beecher's side they she's very much
cultivated by Beecher's side that she is
not called by either side in the trial
because no one knew what she was going
to say at this point they really had no
idea and in this trial she stands up in
the middle and asked the judge she can
read a letter aloud but she does not
allow her to do not you know not kosher
in which he absolutely said repudiates
her earlier confessions however after
the trial of maybe three or four three
years after the trial she's older she's
been pretty much shunned even though he
will he essentially won the trial in the
sense that he was not he was allowed to
go on and have a successful career she
was nonetheless treated like a pariah by
all of his fans all of his fans and all
his friends and the church once once her
she was once they were done with her
quite literally and she wrote a letter
to the New York Times saying you know I
have no reason to lie now and I did have
reason to lie before and under
tremendous pressure I lied and said
did not have an affair with Beecher you
know I lied about everything
but at that point it didn't really
matter because she had you know too many
things and bought too much water had
passed from the bridge and everyone had
read all the evidence all these letters
hundreds of letters and things you
should never save things if you're going
let me just tell you that and try not to
talk to reporters sir I know you in the
back when one featured began to have
doubts about Hell that he can find those
expressions to just just his friends and
acquaintances or did he actually share
them in the pulpit that's a very good
question I you know your man he he began
to have doubts about how long long
before he made any kind of public
pronouncement and he had certainly
stopped preaching about it in any
significant manner he never really was
much of a fire never much for punishment
in fact that is really one of the
interesting things you linking the
politics the religion and the sex
scandal not just now but that was
something people really noticed at the
time is because Henry had suffered so
much as a sinner as a little boy like he
the whipping he would get was never half
as bad as the the anticipation and the
watching of Lyman's face to see if he
caught the lie or if he was going to get
in trouble that he really developed a
theology is out of that out of that that
experience of suffering in that manner
and I really think the experience
perhaps of these clothes scrapes in his
personal life which was sin is not just
a crime sin is suffering sin is a stain
sin is that what we are feeling when we
sin is we are suffering as our souls are
suffering and so he always felt like you
don't need to be punished after that you
don't need to go to hell
you have suffered so much as a sinner
and that's how he treated that's how he
treated the question of hell it's how he
treated the
of whether or not the rebels the
southern rebels should be let back in
heat one of the reasons he got so much
hot water and gotten so much conflict
with Theodore Tilton was he believed
that the rebels should be let in without
any you know without any restriction
certainly without any severe punishment
had they not already suffered enough and
of course the South did suffer greatly
but it is also true that finally after
the scandal after the scandal really
died down and he had recreated his
career as a speaker if not so much as a
writer at one point you know people were
sniping about his unorthodox views and I
think he just decided I I have played
the Orthodox game enough he had always
sort of paid Lix lip service to
orthodoxy even as he did whatever he
wanted and he made a statement the
congregational Association repudiating
held repeating the Westminster catechism
the belief in how and to be quite honest
it got it got some attention we've got
some attention partially because it
dovetails very nicely with of course you
don't believe in hell you know why would
you believe it out yeah you should see
the carto there are cartoons in the book
you can see it actually Henry Road
features will take on hell but at the
same time everyone's like you know he's
been saying that already you know it
didn't it didn't also stir up much you
know ruckus because by that point nobody
nobody thought he believed it anyway
you mentioned a couple of times that the
relationship with his closest sibling
Harriet I wonder if you would amplify on
that as well as his troubled
relationship with his wife well you know
Harry it was very good Harry it was very
good to his wife actually in Harriet and
units were actually pretty close but but
even Harriet who was a loving loving
woman found Eunice everyone found Eunice
difficult and really the problem with
Eunice Eunice was an admirable woman a
very strong woman a real Yankee
fortitude person who was dragged out to
the
middle-of-nowhere Indiana was not a nice
place to live in the 1840s and and
suffered tremendously lost four of her
children five hundred children and and a
terrible suffered tremendously bad
health but it is also true that she was
she was a sourpuss she really was and he
was the exact opposite personality type
where where Beecher was where Henry was
expansive she was pinched where he was
confident she was anxious and where he
cared not a fig what other people
thought she worried tremendously what
people thought about things all the time
and she was very very jealous and in
some ways actually one of the
disappointments of the book along with
them not getting to do enough with
Roxanna and Lyman or having to cut all
that out I had two chapters on them that
had to be cut somewhere you'll find that
so it'll pop up so there is that I had a
lot about Eunice because I felt like I
wanted this to be a portrait of a
marriage as well as a portrait of a
potential philanderer and a lot of that
unfortunate to get cut because really
the lesson was not that Eunice was nasty
and drove him into the arms of other
people if anything quite the opposite he
probably was in so inconsiderate that
she became more shrewish although as we
all know anyone who's married which
comes first the chicken or the egg is a
hard one the nagging or the bad behavior
on the husband's part but what if what
the lesson that someone knows the answer
I'm gonna say the nagging is always
second but the the real lesson was Peter
was so girl-crazy that she was honest
gosh the first woman the first girl who
paid any attention to him had to get
engaged right away because he had to beg
her he had to grab her because she's
paying attention to me and they were 18
years old and they had seven more years
of college and grad of seminary to go to
they didn't see each other for seven
years
I mean they seven-year engagement at the
age of 18 4 or 5 of them separated and
they really were just incompatible and
you know I guess it's a I I should say
it's a lesson against early marriages
but I can't say that because my husband
who many of you met I was standing over
there he I met him only 6 months before
or maybe half a year maybe a little bit
more than a year 9 months before I met
teacher and so you know sometimes it
works like I'm sorry for the microphone
this may be a bit of an off-the-wall
question but you've heard of Emily
Dickinson brother Austin having an
affair with Mabel great book I was just
curious if in your research you ran
across any interesting items that
probably didn't make it into your book
but that we'd be interested in oh gosh
yeah you you that's the wrong question
because at some point you guys want to
leave I have I because it was such a big
project the only way to keep track of
all my notes was to put them in
chronological order as they happened in
the Beecher's life so I have a 1200 page
chronology of the Beecher's life and
time starting with the earlier
generation which I can use to console
myself with that very question every
time I had to cut something I would have
I would put it's okay it's going to be
in the chronology and it is something
that I hoped it will be on file at the
Amber's College archives the archivist
is here here right there and it will
probably be something that we'll have
access to at the stove center and it's
hopefully something I would like to have
posted on the web although that's a very
difficult
I'm sure there's all kinds of legal
questions that I haven't even begun
considering but but that's not really
what you asked you pick one of those
well I actually one of my favorite
stories that did not make it into the
book is actually not about Henry it's
about Harriet like and and I cannot tell
you where I got this off the top of my
head because my memory for these things
it's not as good either but I can look
it up if anyone wants to know is that
they I ran across a story about Harriet
they became very good friends both Henry
and Harriet with the literati especially
in Boston and the fields the Ticknor and
fields publishing company in particular
in the fields Annie fields and her
husband James fields were very good
friends of them both but especially of
Harriet Harriet went one time to Boston
just just visit and was left they said
the people the the the masters of the
house were not at home the the maid let
them in she's let Harriet sit in the
parlor and there was a picture of what
Harriet thought it was iced tea there
and now the features were raised to be
cold not they weren't raised as cold
water temperance people that they became
that for a while but then later on they
got they went to Europe both Henry and
Harriet and and we all know how you know
they've corrupt over there and they
began to be a little bit wine drinkers
but they were still not drinkers well
Harriet was a hot day Harriet is sitting
waiting and waiting in this parlor
reading she's and drinking the iced tea
drinking more and more and more of it
until she has trashed it's some kind of
punch absolutely he decides she's gonna
take a nap on the sofa lays down she's
got hoop skirts on she lays down her
hoop skirts all go up like this so she
you know I mean which in fact oops
courts were in general not consider that
ladylike because you could always see
the ankles because they were always mean
so she's laying there on the sofa her
hopes up like this her legs quite
splayed the maid comes and tries to wake
her up and she's nine you're sort of
like drunk you know like really kind of
like the drunk lady alone and the lady's
finally I believe she comes and fine
put the tablecloth over the hoops
everyone comes in at least they will all
be looking at the legs I would have
loved to put that in the back which is
why unis banned wine from the from the
house as much as possible this will be a
quick question what are you going to do
next I am thinking I'm going to lay
around and eat bonbons until I died of
ennui that's my plan I don't have I have
spent 20 years with the features and
quite frankly who else is going to I
cannot think of anyone else who is gonna
charm me as much and who is worth all
the effort and honestly I really don't
know what I'm gonna do I'm gonna flog
this book until people stop buying it
and I wanted to ask you you mention how
Henry Ward Beecher had had connections
with the Boston Leader rye in perhaps
new york and abraham lincoln so how
about here people like Harley and
Twitchell and Twain oh yeah
a good cart fir'd question actually some
of the funnest things I read or the
really most poignant things are were
Joseph Twitchell who was the those of
you who are not hartford people this
nick farm area was an enclave of writers
and cultural arbiters in which and this
is where Harriet lived an Isabella lived
and Mary Perkins the other sister all
lived here as well as Mark Twain and any
number of other really very impressive
writers and feature of course spent lots
of time here it was a favorite stopping
spot especially because the railroad
came right through here
he was bien he befriended Mark Twain
very early on Mark Twain actually that's
one of the better parts of the book Mark
Twain becomes very good friends with
Beecher right off the bat and Beecher
him on how to sign his first contract is
very first book contract for what became
one of his biggest bestsellers innocents
abroad and innocence abroad especially
in its early form when it was newspaper
excuse me
newspaper essays of the Quaker city tour
the very first the May first luxury tour
live what he would call it cruise - a
cruise a luxury cruise ship to the to
the Holy Land Twain leisure was supposed
to go on that and in fact one of the
Cooke holds mr. Brewster beaches violets
father fled because violet had been born
right before that and he was very upset
he wouldn't say why he was just very
upset and he fled and went on the Quaker
City tour with Mark Twain in fact Mark
Twain tried to marry his daughter and
when when he came back
Twain had written these quite kind of
snotty I mean quite snide really and
kind of nasty attacks on the Christians
who had been on this Quaker City tour
really making fun of them mercilessly
and Beecher said bright that's that's
that's a book and canceled them and
found how to sign a really great
contract for it and one of the things I
always find very funny is that between
we not really been able to set up and be
the nuke farm grand heed that he would
have had it not been Beecher telling him
how to make money off of making fun of
Christians and it's a little shocking
actually
in fact Twain wrote it as a very lovely
quote after going to dinner at Beecher's
house about that liquor question there's
a really lovely time they only drink
cider and I said it I said it to mr.
Beecher too bad there's no champagne
he's yeah I think so do i but Twitchell
joseph Twitchell who was the minister to
the new farm community he wrote some of
the best descriptions of the trial
because he and Mark Twain together they
were very close friends went down and
visited the trial and I've included a
lot of them in the book because he's
just he captures it so beautifully he
wants to believe Beecher he gets very
nervous because it really doesn't look
good for him but in the end features are
so lovable and so candid even
he's hedging even when he's not being
candid that in the end Twitchell I think
represents most Americans by coming
around and saying you know of course
he's innocent of course yeah I had a
question I my great-great uncle Samuel
was a delegate from Cheshire to a
Congregational council that went on in
1876 and the person he uses very
pejorative terms about as a mr. bowen oh
yes he's really quite specific and what
he says about him but is that after the
trial or first of all you're killing me
because I really wish I'd seen that I
have to tell you uncle Samuel diaries
are very interesting so I do go to the
computer and write things out when I
find they are interesting so I have a
copy of what I've done on that
afterwards I need to work more on the
beaches but Henry Bowen is he's a big
character in the book and he is in in
many ways the the villain of the book I
hate to say it I mean in many ways he
was also put upon by Beecher he is the
man who brought feature out from the
West hoots back to New York
he's not exactly discovery but he paid
for him paid for all of expenses he lent
him money he was features biggest patron
in Brooklyn and Beecher frankly was not
a lovable man but not very reliable he
didn't pay back his debts he oboe and
owned also the New York independent for
whom Beecher wrote and for and Bowen
hired Theodore Tilton and it was Bowen
in fact who told Theodore about all
these rumors about the women and it was
rumoured and I don't know whether to
believe this I I feel very ambivalent
and I have no proof on this one but it
was rumored that Beecher also had an
affair with Henry Bowens wife Lucy I
really don't she died and when she died
Beecher was very upset but you know he's
very hard to say about that I would and
so unfortunately Bowen was his greatest
supporter
and then becomes his nemesis and he is
really a big part of what drives the
scandal and that would be why that's
precisely why why my great-great
grandmother was living on Brooklyn
Heights at the time so the family was
very involved and a family came here to
go to the Kathryn Beecher school and so
on so oh that's a great it really should
be over there
Oh your repository oh there might be
some fighting here though I'm sorry I
shouldn't keep we can have repository
competition
I should probably one more question is
there anything else there's one one here
and then I'm sorry didn't mean to keep
her run so long well this is a good
question to end on how did his life in
what were the last years of his life
like he had a really a really good last
ten years in some ways he he read he
actually made a lot of money because
even though people were not really
interested in you know here hearing his
opinions I like reading his essays he
never made any more money writing really
because although he did get a contract
to write his memoirs but died before
then but people were willing to go see
him speak because they wanted to see is
he a libertine or not and so that in
fact the crowds were often very hostile
and over and over again he won them over
and really created a very profitable
very lucrative even more lucrative them
before career as a speaker and he kept
his job he kept his post as pastor and
spent a fortune building a gorgeous
house in Peekskill New York on the
Hudson which is is still there although
split into condos he had it's still
there
and oh and of course spent all his money
on the house and left his wife without a
dime when he died actually well any
pterence policy but for someone who'd
made well over a million dollars in his
lifetime really one more poor crime for
unis
to complain about
fair enough but but he also did he had
two things he had some very noble things
he he came out against and then does
that he spoke out four against the
Chinese Exclusion Act against prejudice
against the the Chinese workers against
anti-semitism which was beginning to
rise against business people in against
the effort to try to promote to make
Bible reading Protestant Bible reading
requisite in the schools to force the
Catholics to become a partisan he spoke
out against all these prejudices that
were really quite noble in a wonderful
way he also on the other hand supported
Grover Cleveland now yeah I'm not saying
that Grover Cleveland was not not a good
guy but Grover Cleveland did in fact
have an illegitimate child before before
being elected and that came out in the
middle of the campaign just after
betrayed decided to defect from the
Republicans to support him and he had to
really decide what he was going to do
and in fact in fact that the campaign is
um Grover Cleveland campaign is known
for I think the precious campaign diddy
mama where's my paw gone to the White
House hahaha and future decided to heck
with it he was going to support him and
he really came out in a big way in a way
that a lot of people found quite vulgar
and really made him look guilty err in
some ways because you know he stood up
and said you know I'm gonna stand by
Cleveland the way my church stood by me
well but Cleveland had admitted that he
actually had a child so his perch was
not happy about that and you know at one
point you know he's at a political
sermons you know if every man in New
York who would you know violated the
seventh commandment you know voted you
know we'd have you we'd have adulterers
in all our offices you know which is
just not seemly you know but then again
one of the things that feature is you
know propriety that I guess one of the
things I love the propriety is not has
rather be honest
mostly honest
then proper well thank you so much
Debbie Applegate on Henry Ward Beecher
brother of Harriet Beecher Stowe from
the Harriet Beecher Stowe's Center in
Hartford Connecticut for more
information on the center visit harriet
beecher stowe center